[Musica]
nell'arco dell'ultimo anno durante la
pandemia o nell'ordine comprato un
computer che mi ha permesso di scaricare
degli applicativi per poter lavorare in
modo più efficace da casa con i miei
colleghi ma mi ha permesso anche di
raggiungere degli amici di raggiungere i
parenti
così come l'utilizzo di un cellulare mi
ha permesso di andare a raggiungere i
miei nonni senza andare a casa loro e
quindi senza il rischio e la paura di
contagiarli ecco questo strumento non è
l'unico perché poi ho sottoscritto un
abbonamento presso una piattaforma
online che mi ha permesso non solo di
partecipare ma anche di organizzare
degli eventi privati e degli eventi
pubblici o così partecipato dei consigli
del quartiere a delle assemblee
pubbliche a delle assemblee civiche e
col computer
giusto ieri ho perfino votato per la
rielezione di un direttivo di
un'associazione ma cosa più importante
ho partecipato per la prima volta nella
mia vita a un incontro o un colloquio
con le maestre mio figlio naturalmente
tutto online
ecco questo non è un elenco
pubblicitario ma mi serve per dire che
sicuramente tutti questi strumenti
digitali e questi servizi che io ho
potuto beneficiare che ho potuto
accedere hanno permesso per me di non
fermarmi e soprattutto di non subire i
danni pesanti della pandemia che gli
effetti dei log dow quindi ho battuto
dei costi o ridotto delle distanze o
eliminato delle distanze o ridotto dei
tempi tutto ciò assolutamente rimanendo
in contatto con i miei colleghi i miei
familiari
i miei amici bene questo però è stato
possibile per me perché io avevo delle
possibilità e mi capita spesso di vivere
un sentimento di frustrazione di
ingiustizia e di impotenza
quando la notte piove forte io sono
dentro casa mia e
io sono dentro una coperta a letto con
un tetto che mi protegge e penso invece
a tante persone che sono per strada
questo per dire che lo stesso sentimento
di frustrazione e di impotenza di
ingiustizia
io lo vivo tutti i giorni di questa
pandemia quando penso che questi servizi
questi strumenti informatici che per me
sono stati una grandissima opportunità
per altri invece sono stati una barriera
una barriera che non gli ha impedito di
incontrare persone non gli ha permesso
di partecipare attivamente ad una vita
sociale e non gli ha permesso
magari di vedere delle occasioni di
lavoro di sfruttare delle occasioni di
lavoro o perfino di richiedere delle
prestazioni di servizi essenziali che
gli avrebbero salvato la vita e che gli
avrebbero sicuramente allungato il
futuro è dato delle delle possibilità
migliori
a me questa cosa della disuguaglianza
non mi è mai andata giù e non mi ha mai
fatto dormire bene perché c'è un
articolo l'articolo 3 della costituzione
italiana che dice che la repubblica la
nostra repubblica democratica si impegna
a rimuovere ogni ostacolo di natura
sociale di natura economica che di fatto
limitando la libertà e l'uguaglianza di
ciascun cittadino ne impedisce il pieno
sviluppo
ecco nel 2021 quegli ostacoli
sicuramente vengono rimossi anche e
soprattutto e sarà sempre di più
attraverso degli strumenti informatici e
dei servizi digitali
e quindi importante che quello che noi
facciamo oggi è investire e credere
fermamente che il mondo digitale possa
salvare la vita possa rivoluzionare la
vita di tante persone che oggi vivono in
uno stato di povertà
però per farlo dobbiamo permettere a
queste persone di poter accedere a degli
strumenti digitali dobbiamo permettere a
queste persone
conoscere come utilizzare questo oggi
non avviene questo oggi non avviene
perché tanti motivi per tanti motivi il
primo fra tutti è che per accedere a dei
servizi della pubblica amministrazione
italiana è necessario avere un'identità
digitale
badate bene questa è una cosa bella è un
investimento grande che sta facendo lo
stato italiano ed è sicuramente una
strada da perseguire
l'utilizzo dell'identità digitale in
particolare di un sistema pubblico di
identificazione digitale low speed però
per ottenere lo speed per poter fruire
di servizi della pubblica
amministrazione anche servizi essenziali
è necessario prima di tutto essere
riconosciuti e identificabili in un
mondo reale e questo può sembrare
pazzesco nel 2021
quando i social media i principali
social media conoscono tutto quello che
facciamo conoscono i nostri
comportamenti i nostri gusti
quello che ci piace mangiare la musica
che vorremmo ascoltare
eppure nel 2021 ancora oggi nelle nostre
città ci sono persone che sono
invisibili invisibili di fatto perché
non identificate e non identificabili
capita quando per esempio una persona
senza tetto una persona senza fissa
dimora
quelli che noi chiamiamo clochard in
modo forse un po romantico che vive per
strada non ha una carta d'identità la
carta d'identità e quel documento di
riconoscimento o cartaceo plastificato
fisico materiale che ci permette di
dimostrare chi siamo ma non ci permette
solo di dimostrare chi siamo
ci permette anche poi di poter accedere
e ottenere un identità digitale si
perché lo speed si può ottenere
solamente se abbiamo una carta di unità
semplice solamente quindi se c'è stato
prima un atto di riconoscimento da parte
dello stato che dice bene chi siamo
ma per tante persone questo non è
possibile perché se il comune se l'ente
locale se il luogo la città dove la
persona senza tetto senza fissa dimora
vive non lo riconosce non lo vuole
riconoscere fa finta che non esista
perché ha un costo
perché disturba perché puzza perché
ingombrante perché non è bello da vedere
allora quella persona non verrà
registrata all'anagrafe e iscriversi
all'anagrafe di un comune rappresenta la
porta d'accesso per tutta una serie di
servizi e rappresenta la possibilità per
poter avere la carta d'identità carta
d'identità che poi mi permetterà di
avere un'identità digitale che poi mi
permetterà di ottenere tutta una serie
di servizi e benefici del mondo digitale
e sono quei servizi quei benefici che
paradossalmente sono proprio quelli
pensati per le persone senza fissa
dimora perché pensate attraverso un
click una persona senza fissa dimora
senza costi senza dover andare da un
interprete da un da un professionista ad
un intermediario senza dover quindi
pagare nessuno potrebbe con un click
presentare delle stanze alla pubblica
amministrazione chiedere sussidi
chiedere bonus che delle prestazioni
chiedere pensioni ma anche chiedere
mettersi in graduatoria per un alloggio
popolare e soprattutto con un click
potrebbe evitare di recarsi ad uno
sportello fisico dove c'è un'altra
barriera enorme che tutt'oggi nel 2021 è
forte ed è invalicabile lo stigma
sociale cioè la vergogna e l'imbarazzo
di essere una persona che vive per
strada l'imbarazzo di magari aver
dormito la sera prima per strada di non
essersi fatto una doccia e di doversi
quindi recare ad uno sportello dove
probabilmente verrà respinto però
giudicato quello stigma sociale
attraverso invece l'utilizzo di
strumenti informatici potrebbe essere
annientato abbattuto permettendo quindi
a una persona in uno stato di povertà
che prova vergogna e l'imbarazzo di
questa sua condizione di riuscire invece
ad arrivare direttamente allo stato
nelle braccia dello stato questo sarebbe
perfetto perché sarebbe assolutamente il
culmine di una vita democratica della
realizzazione di un piano di uguaglianza
però l'ostacolo dell'identificazione non
è l'unico non è l'unica barriera che
impedisce la rete
l'azione di una società democratica
anche in un mondo virtuale perché ci
sono tanti altre questioni aperte e la
pandemia amplificato le disuguaglianze
amplificato le disparità in quei settori
in quegli ambiti in cui gli strumenti
informatici hanno preso fortunatamente
il dominio comunque quantomeno la
preferenza pensiamo all'istruzione
pensiamo alla sanità pensiamo alla
giustizia
se uno studente oggi dovesse fare una
didattica distanza senza avere uno
strumento informatico adeguato senza
avere una connessione stabile e sicura
come possiamo pretendere che questa
persona abbia la possibilità di godere
sud è suo diritto all'istruzione
se un anziano che è fermo immobile nella
sua casa impossibilitato magari malato
non può chiedere una ricetta medica
oppure non può scaricare l'esito del suo
esame medico attraverso un'applicazione
perché non ne conosce l'utilizzo dello
strumento del telefono del computer del
tablet
ecco che verrà compromesso o comunque
quantomeno ostacolata la sua possibilità
di godere pienamente di questo diritto
alla salute e allo stesso modo pensiamo
alla giustizia io quest'anno ho
celebrato tantissime udienze online da
remoto
se il mio cliente non avesse potuto
collegarsi da remoto o non avessi io ho
potuto incontrarlo mediante strumenti
digitali correndo gli strumenti digitali
e mi è successo che tante persone non
hanno preso appuntamento con me per
questo forse è ostacolato anche su
diritto alla difesa
ma ecco poi pensiamo ancora un po più in
grande e pensiamo alla libertà di
pensiero alla possibilità di associarsi
e di riunirsi tutti questi sono diritti
costituzionalmente garantiti e se noi
pensiamo che le principali assemblee
civiche i consigli comunali le consulte
di quartiere sono oggi quasi tutti
tenuti in modalità web in her on line
videoconferenze
alla sera se una persona
degli strumenti informatici per potersi
collegare non ancora una volta una
connessione che sia pubblica anche
gratuita oa basso costo
questa persona è completamente tagliata
fuori dalla sua possibilità di
partecipare attivamente alla vita della
città
se pensiamo alla grecia all'antica
grecia il luogo principe dove si
esercitava la vita democratica dove si
intersecavano la la vita commerciale la
vita culturale la vita politica di una
comunità era lavorano una piazza un
luogo aperto o noi consideriamo e
crediamo fermamente che nella
trasposizione di questa agorà in uno
spazio virtuale per usufruire di tutte
le possibilità
lasciamo che lavorassi a uno spazio
aperto pubblico accessibile a tutti
oppure la piazza diventerà una stanza la
piazza diventerà un nuovo chiuso dove un
moderatore deciderà arbitrariamente chi
far entrare e chi fa scegliere quindi da
spazio democratico ci sarà un circolo di
elite poche persone
l'antitesi della democrazia ecco quindi
che se vogliamo investire come dobbiamo
in una società democratica che si
esercita anche in uno spazio virtuale
non dobbiamo dimenticarci che prima
della democrazia virtuale c'è una
democrazia reale fatta di cittadini che
devono essere uguali e che sono in carne
ed ossa